how does someone take action toward
their goals
when they can barely get out of bed in
the morning they don't
i think the action that they work on is
getting out of bed in the morning
you know we can sometimes feel
overwhelmed with all the things we need
to do or want to do
but if you're feeling that way if you're
feeling like i can't get out of bed in
the morning
you really just want to focus on the
task at hand which is like
you know abraham talks about um
you don't have to jump the emotional
scale so if you're feeling really low
you don't have to try to jump to feeling
amazing and going for your dreams and
doing all your goals you know doing all
the actions for your goals
it's about incremental increases like
could i just feel a little bit better
can i somehow focus on getting myself
better so i feel good enough to get out
of bed
can i then maybe take a shower or could
i maybe do some exercise to
get my heart rate going and build those
endorphins and just
take care of myself you know can i can i
climb that ladder
so that from here then you can feel a
little better in here
and then here right and you you're
incrementally climbing so that when you
get to a place then when you can finally
start to feel good
then you can focus on going for your
goals
but i think that you know our mental
health
is so much more important than any goal
and so
it's so important i always tell my
clients too like your alignment
your energy should be your priority
above all you know so if you
are feeling really rejected one day and
you're feeling really down
don't go email 10 more agents because
you don't feel good you know wait until
you feel better
work on make your energy the priority
work on what can i do to make myself
feel better to
shift my energy that has to be my
priority then i'll go take those actions
because you really want to take the
action from a place where you feel good
so that you get that reflected back to
you
plus when you're feeling good you'll be
led to better ideas
you know when you're when you can't even
get out of bed you're not going to have
that amazing idea you know to take some
new risk
and going back to your job scenario
which is a great example
you finally got this one job which was
more of a survival job
and it really helped you yes just get
out of your own mindset
all this stuff and then that's when the
re the job that you really wanted
came calling totally totally and again
that's why i say like i'm so grateful
for that waitressing job you know really
helped shift my energy and
get me out of feeling depressed and yeah
that did
really good things for me yeah what do
you consider
the impossible dream well the title of
my book
has that word in quotes in the subtitle
because i don't think that anything's
impossible i really don't and i i
i know that sounds cheesy oh nothing's
impossible but
you can't think that anything you want
is impossible or else you'll never go
for it
in the manner that it's going to require
so
i don't think anything's impossible i
think other people might tell you that
they think it's impossible
you know there might be data or evidence
that suggests it might be challenging
but any obstacle or any challenge
to me that's that's not enough
information to say oh
that's too impossible i shouldn't do it
i shouldn't even try so
yeah i don't believe that anything is
impossible
how would you handle if one of your
clients was giving up on their quote
unquote hollywood dream
and you feel like maybe that's the right
decision for them
i've never felt that way ever i would
never feel that way
tim again though it's not a it's not my
decision it's not up to me
i you know i would never decide if
someone should go for it or not or if
someone should quit or not
that has to come from them alone and so
i would just
encourage them to get in touch with
their true desires and their true
feelings
to help them figure out what's the right
move for them
you know i don't think there's anything
wrong with someone saying i want to do
something else now instead like that's
okay too i mean look at me i
worked in television for all these years
and then i was like i want to coach i
want to help other people
so you know our dreams change sometimes
but
i would never be the one to tell someone
that they
should quit or they shouldn't do this
have you ever seen it where someone
comes
to you and they say you know i'm not
getting to x y and d in my career
and then you realize well this was just
the total wrong path for them
no you've never seen that no no again
like i i like i know i romanticize it a
little bit but i also think that that
is a super power like i think it's okay
that i romanticize it because that has
led to my success
but i truly believe if they have this
dream
then they can make it happen and so it's
really it really just comes back down to
them having the desire
if you have a desire for a dream i will
help you i believe that you can make it
happen
it's as simple as that for me when did
you first hear of abraham hicks
oh gosh years ago i don't remember
five years ago maybe i i went to one of
their live events
a couple years ago yeah
maybe five or six years ago and it's all
about
manifestation it's it's law of
attraction you know esther hicks
channels
um an entity called abraham i know
that's very weird if you're new
it might be too for you but um but it's
just
information about law of attraction
where people just ask them questions
and they answer and it's no matter what
they ask it's very applicable to
anyone's what they're going through
anyone's life so um
yeah so i've been listening for years
because it helps me and i like it
what are the big problems that are
arising for artists
during covid and how are you helping
them through it
i love this question because i have been
humbled
with the answer to this question i have
really learned a lot
i have seen proof during covid that
absolutely anything
is possible and to me that is
incredible for i always give these
examples sarah cooper i don't know if
you know sarah cooper
she's a comedian a writer she posted on
social media these funny videos
are on tick tock i think and she blew up
and she was already like i think she was
already doing some work but she just
blew up
during the pandemic while hollywood is
shut down
like things aren't even filming at all
and she ends up getting a netflix
special
and she also was invited to do the i
think the opening night monologue on one
of the late night tv shows and she did a
phenomenal job i watched it was so
impressed
it's a great example of like even when
the industry is shut down
opportunities still exist and to me that
has been so humbling because
you know i can fall into the victim mode
of like oh my gosh this is so hard i
mean look you know my business i lost 60
of my business during the pandemic but i
did pivot and i was like well how else
can i serve people right now how else
can i help people right now instead of
just throwing in the towel right
so i think you know the way that i'm
supporting my clients during the
pandemic is a little different now
because things have started up and
things are filming i mean not
as much as before but things are filming
but i'm really you know empowering them
to believe that their dreams are still
possible during this time
i mean there are other artists that have
you know really blown up and gotten a
lot of attention and opportunity during
this time
caitlyn reilly is another example her
instagram account blew up she does this
like hilarious 60 second videos that
people really related to
and really loved and her account blew up
i see she getting like sponsor deals now
you know so it's been humbling it's like
erica come on you teach this that
anything is possible
and and so um that's been exciting for
me to learn you know
like really anything is possible at any
time
there's no wrong time to pursue your
dream even this pandemic i don't think
it's the wrong
time and you started your book in
february 2020 yeah
i started writing in february yes wow
yeah right so i wrote a book during the
pandemic you know
yeah and now you're doing the audio book
yes wow
yes so you're basically saying okay one
one
part you know you said you're pivoting
so at what point did you
say okay i'm showing up at the computer
today to write this first page of this
book
i i don't mean to sound annoying but
like i never struggled with that
oh okay i just didn't i because like
when i got the i
so the idea for the book wasn't a
strategic pivoting move from the
pandemic
it was just happened to be like in
december of the previous year of 2019
december
october november december is when i
started to get the nudge to write the
book
um and so i was already planning to do
it before the pandemic happened
um and i just i i talk about this in the
book but
it just felt like i was divinely guided
to write this book and i had to get this
message out and so
it it was a challenging uh
path in terms of like i rewrote the
first chapter 100 times you know
that it was it was challenging and
finding my voice and how i
you know do i want this book to just be
for hollywood or do i want it to be for
everyone and
that was an interesting learning
experience figuring that you know
solving that problem and figuring
out do i want this message to be
applicable applicable to everyone and if
i do
how much hollywood do i include how much
do i exclude
so there was you know challenges in in
that aspect but
i never really struggled with like oh my
gosh i have to sit down at the computer
today and write this
right going back you said you're a
self-starter yes i just felt very
inspired to do it but like look the
audiobook is taking me forever because
because it's so much work and i'm not
really sitting i've only recorded like a
chapter and a half so
you